hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round four of
the video world cup it's divided versus
jeffrey xiong and
in the first round uh vidit was able to
win with the black pieces so now
uh she needs the bonds back with the
with the black pieces in classical game
in order
to figure force tie breaks and while uh
today is reserved for
uh the players who have tied their match
and will be going um into tiebreaks we
are going to check out at least one more
game uh from yesterday and
the first one is vedic versus xiong it's
a really enjoyable game and it features
the
absolute best bishop pair of the
tournament so as you can imagine
it will be fully operational so without
further ado let's check it out
with it with the white pieces opens with
d4
we have d6 knight to f3 knight to f6 and
now
c4 uh we have g6 sort of the old indian
defense we have g3
bishop to g7 bishop to g2 and now bishop
to f5 so it's it's not new it has been
played before we have queen to b3 now
taking advantage of black's bishop
already being developed so
uh it comes with tempo we have queen to
c8 defending the b7 pawn
and now uh having some ideas of maybe if
white castles then we can already play
bishop h3 maybe trade off the light
square bishops
and so on so knight to c3 video
continues development
we have c6 now uh and the both players
castle so castles castles and
rook to e1 now we have bishop to g4
and e4 white now grabs a lot of space in
the center here and the black
fights for the e5 square so he wants to
eliminate the defender of the e5 square
so bishop captures bishop captures and
e5 now and here
there is one game in the database where
bishop to e3 was played just continuing
development but here
vidiq plays d captures on e5 and it is
as of move 12 that we have a completely
new game
also worth considering is maybe d5 but
vidit has a very clear plan of what he
wants to do and
it will pose a lot of problems for black
as you'll see
so the captures on e5 we have d captures
and now
c5 grabbing uh even more space here
controlling the
uh the d6 square and now if you can you
know get some pieces uh
over there on that square it's going to
be very very hard for
black to play this for the moment the
knight can't really reach the square
uh but you can you know shift it
somewhere like maybe d1 to e3 to c4 to
d6 or you know maybe put some rooks on
these
all depends on what uh black will play
so here we have knight to a6
attacking the c5 pawn and the bishop to
e3 now defending it
we have knights to c7 uh and now comes
rook a to d1 so this knight cannot maybe
come to e6 maybe it can come to d4 in
the future
white will of course try to try to
prevent this so knight the e6
and bishop the queen to c4 now making
room for the pawn to come to b4
to help out with the defense of the c5
pawn
so h5 by black and now knight to e2 and
this is a
a very uh reasonable move since the
knight
doesn't really have any any good options
here you have to figure out
a way of of how to uh better introduce
the knight into the game
as soon two once said uh the strength of
a player is determined by how well he
maneuvers his knights
that that is a true story so knights the
e2 the knight can now
will uh go go to many many different
squares
uh we have uh rook the d8 uh getting the
rook to the to the open d
file and now bishop to g2 now you can
play f3 f4 probably f3
as well if it already won the first game
you don't want to do anything too crazy
but even f4 f5 might be an idea in the
future
so here at knights the g4 before white
gets this f3 move in
uh black takes this opportunity to
harass the dark square bishop so bishop
back to c1
and now rook captures on the one rook
captures and now
uh the other rook also needs to join the
game so queen to f8 preparing to bring
the rook here
uh we have f3 chasing the knight away
knight to f6
and now b4 saying okay what do you play
here
and you can't really play b6 to try and
undermine the structure like this that
weakens the c6 pawn but you can play a5
you want to open up the a file for your
rook so that's what the xiong does
we have a3 characters captures and now
knight the e8 black also knows um
the famous until quote so he also starts
maneuvering his knights
uh and now f4 and it's a really ugly
move to see black played
the the knight to e8 he wants to come to
c7 then to b5 and then gain control
more control over the d4 square and at
some point land the knight there on d4
but
wit it says uh nope uh we are starting
our attack here i'm playing f5 next so
what are you gonna do here now capturing
here a video will capture with the g
pawn so of course
f5 will come at uh you know it
at any end all expense so here queen to
e7
uh and now bishop to h3 uh but it even
prepares the the pawn push we have
knight
eight to c7 uh preparing to bring the
knight to b5 then to d4 like we said
and now f5 and you have to capture this
if you just move the knight then we can
capture here for free because the f pawn
is pinned
so g captures with uh e captures on f5
uh not e captures on f5 e captures on f5
would be
uh would be giving black a bit too much
if we do this then knight's the d4
and it's uh well it's a very nice
position for black black already has a
past pawn here and even if you capture
for example captures captures now he has
a nicely defended pass pawn here
uh maybe not the the best so here we
have bishop captures an f5 by viridit
now the bishop uh uh still stuck on g7
without all that much to do and the e5
pawn
uh is not uh for uh on d4 or anywhere
else where it can be pushed further
so here we have knight to b5 black
continues with his plan of course and
bishop to b2 now putting more pressure
here along
this diagonal uh and now we have a
waiting move
bishop to f6 not just a waiting move the
bishop is coming to f6 so later on you
can place the bishop on g5
if needed uh if you go for knights to d4
right away
uh you could play this for example
knight capture spawn captures uh but you
know
it's uh uh it's it's a pretty crazy
position and
uh although a crazy position is
something that black wants to
have on the board he needs to win this
game uh it doesn't uh
he he doesn't have like a clear way of
how to how to continue this
so instead after bishop to b2 we have
bishop to f6
uh like i said this bishop can come to
g5 if needed
and now queen to b3 now that it says all
right but what about your
h5 pawn how are you going to defend this
uh well there is
really no good way we have knight e to
d4 now attacking the queen
and now knight captures on d4 uh and
here we have e captures on d4 you could
also play knight capture on d4
uh and then for example if queen to e3
now we can play bishop to g5 and it's uh
maybe uh
uh maybe a better better uh not better
maybe a better than what happened in the
actual game position for black
uh but xion needs to go for a win so he
has to play e
captures on the e4 we have queen to f3
going after the h5
pawn and now knight the c3 uh also very
interesting is d3 as the bishop here is
undefended and then we can maybe trade
captures captures and after we grab this
rook play rook to a2
and again it's not much but it's maybe
uh you know
uh uh maybe a nice active position for
black but white will always be better
but it's maybe
something to hope for with black xiong
uh thinks this is a bit too much he
plays
knights the c3 instead attacks the rook
here we have rook to d2 and now
rook to a4 going after the b4 pawn
now that it captures on h5 we have rook
captures on b4 and now
king to g2 you could uh maybe try
and um uh not sorry and not play this
move but
with the things that uh the king will be
much safer there
so knight the a4 attacking the bishop
twice and now
bishop to c1 and here king to f8 you
don't want your king stuck here
uh so how do you how do you continue
this attack with white well
first rook to a2 and it's a really
really powerful move because it
completely
uh removes all counter play from black
you can't move the knight
if you allow the rook to come to a8 it's
all over uh the rook can't really move
anywhere as
the knight would fall uh there's no good
move here for black if queen captures
and c5 bishop a3 wins on the spot
this is just too much to allow for white
so instead we have queen to e5
uh but it's not not much better we have
bishop to f4 now attacking the queen
queen captures on c5 and now queen to h6
with
check now you can't block with the
bishop if you block with the bishop then
we again
win the queen now the the king and queen
are are both attacked by the bishop the
queen nicely defends the bishop here
so instead after this queen to h6 check
we have king to e7
but now white has a very very uh
interesting move that's also the only
winning move
in the position so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for vidit
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
incredible move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's queen
to f8
check a beautiful queen sack that of
course is a joke i hope
none of you thought i was serious uh the
actual winning move is
e5 and that's it there's nothing more to
be done here
uh the problem is uh you can't really
accept this because once you open up the
e file then the rook is coming to e2 for
example bishop capture so we can now
either bring the rook or we can play
bishop g5
now the bishops uh really take away all
the squares from the king the queen
covers the entire sixth string the queen
covers
the the f8 square so not a lot of
squares here you can play king to e8 but
now rook to a2
uh just wins uh on the spot if queen d5
checking h3
and now there's really no defense
against queen to h8 checkmate even
though the bishop covers that
uh of course the bishop will not be able
to capture due to the pin
and that's it you could prolong a little
bit with f6 but you know
it's pretty much pointless so instead
after e5 we have
the immediate queen to d5 check now
connecting with the rook but
white really doesn't care king to h3 and
now you can't really go for the rook
it's uh it's
uh you know just uh suicide if you
capture the rook it's just e captures on
f6 with
check and the bishops controls uh the
bishops control
all the squares you can't really do
anything here only two squares for the
black king
but all of them uh just the resulting
queen to h8 checkmate
so after king h3 we have bishop capture
sun e5 but still
just rook to e2 uh attacking the the
bishop here
we have f6 defending but now the uh
simplest way to end the game and the
quickest one it's actually a force check
made in seven
uh we've reached the position from the
thumbnail so of course you know what is
what
uh and that move of course is rook
captures on e5
and it was in this position on 43 that
jeffrey xiong resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so uh to give you an example if the rook
is accepted
then the full power of the bishop pair
again can be felt
king to e8 now we're going to go into
this queen to h8 checking
the f7 and the king is of course in a
mating web uh king f8 and now queen the
e7 check king here we're going to
deliver a check here king here and now a
nice
bishop checkmate so always nice when
when we can do something like this
and if you don't do this after rook
captures on e5 your other option is just
to start running away with the king
but now it's even nicer uh yes you could
always
move the rook somewhere to deliver a
check but first queen to f8 check this
is the nicest way
came to c7 now we pick up the queen with
check also connect with the rook on b4
king to b6 we grab the rook with check
king to a7 and now of course
rook to a5 will be checkmate as the
bishop covered covers the b8 square
so really really awesome stuff from
vidit winning two classical games like
this finishing a game in such great
style and uh
i am definitely uh proclaiming this game
at least
up to this point the greatest bishop
pair game of the tournament as you can
see here the bishop pair was
truly truly fully operational
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank anshuranjan
harry walk johan bridger
tom derelo and steven binder for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
beautiful tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day